it's nice of you to be here thank you
you know I actually do have something
here I'm here to promote and I'd love to
play a little game if you're up for it
do you guys have port - yeah I'm gonna
list some things and you guys are gonna
guess which one of these things I'm
actually here to promote okay all right
the first one is my new line of
underwear made from thinly sliced
organic ham this this actually this
crazed actually started with Donald
Trump at his rallies the underwear that
he's wearing is actually made from prime
sirloin steak which is what locks in the
moisture very nice I'm I'm wearing the
prosciutto Bray yeah
you can smell it you know a lot of
prosciutto say it's not that one I don't
think it's that ok uh this is a 100 case
open my new documentary about dolphins
and how to stop them dolphins are the
single greatest threat to our borders
they're coming in by the thousands I've
been all over the country ask anyone ok
all right let's take a look at a clip no
no we're not gonna look at a clever
no clip no what are you so afraid I just
know alright look [ __ ] no clarity
my new parenting book ten easy steps to
lower your child's self
yeah I like that once a cocky
know-it-all kid not this guy okay here's
something else I got right here that's
surprising that's Reynolds Wrap that's
you I have no affiliation it's just a
damn good product although I did launch
my own line of Reynolds Wrap condoms
which failed to take off Oh didn't work
they threatened to sue me back into my
father's balls and they weren't
functional they were actually made of
Egyptian cotton oh no it's not that's
not what you you no no no no okay uh oh
here's another walkie something I
recently unearthed sex tape between me
and the cast of Fox and Friends
tentatively titled can you guess where
my son is
honestly I just I just glad that I have
my thumb back yeah yeah touch and go
there for a minute let's roll the clip
no no no no clap No
why aren't you helping me no clip I
don't want to see that no clip alright
fine
well I'm just staring at his thumb yeah
and everything I know from the funds my
album of children's songs about civil
war wounds that's the worst idea I've
ever heard why I've heard bad ideas
that's the worst one
oh yeah what'd you try rhyming gangrene
ten different ways buddy and let's see
how you're into it
[Music]
not having it not having it
okay finally a clip from my new film The
Notebook 2 starring notebook 2 starring
Ryan Reynolds and Conan McAdams ok
I don't recall being involved in
anything like this like well do you
remember that vacation that we took in
Tijuana a couple years ago when we split
that bottle of you split that bottle of
absinthe okay all right well we fell in
love and I filmed it
oh yeah sure sure you did
sure let's roll the rolling
pretty please
why didn't you write me why it wasn't
over for me I waited for you for seven
years and now it's too late
I wrote you 365 letters I wrote you
every day for a year
you wrote me yes you wasn't over still
is
[Applause]
ringing any bells starting to come back
to me now
how's my stomach taste longest tongue in
show business my god I got my tongue
Wade oh my god that was really something
they're going home again it's time for
you oh yeah you're not going home I'm
not going home you there wait no Andy
we're crashing with you okay all right
it's gonna get kinky
I'll get the rain machine
you